foreign
Globes happened two nights ago and I'm
telling you this because the chances are
you didn't already know I only knew
because part of my job is to scour the
internet for all the news of the day
including the most obscure bits of news
like the Golden Globe Awards awards and
if the ratings aren't any any indication
it would seem that most people were
unaware or aware and totally
uninterested in the Golden Globes
um now they didn't air last year at all
because the people who run the show had
to take a year off to confront their
racism or whatever but this year's show
was down 20 compared to 2021's broadcast
and that show in 21 was down
exponentially compared to the year
before so nobody cares about this stuff
anymore and fewer and fewer people care
every year
I'm not here to tell you that you should
care I'm only here to cancel someone
because that's the segment and today it
must be the host of the Golden Globes
for 2023. Gerard Carmichael Carmichael
is an alleged comedian best known for
coming out of the closet during one of
his Netflix specials the Golden Globes
needed to find someone who checked
multiple diversity boxes and as a gay
black man Carmichael fit the bill but is
he actually a good comedian or a skilled
show host
well that consideration was not
important
and it became very obvious that it
wasn't important very quickly during
Carmichael's opening monologue which you
can see part of here
I'm here because I'm black
[Applause]
I'll catch everyone in the room up
you settle down a little bit I'll tell
you what's been going on
this show
the Golden Globe awards did not air last
year
because
the Hollywood Foreign Press Association
which I I won't say they were a racist
organization
but
they didn't have a single black member
until George Floyd died
so do with that information what you
will
why am I here on the stage with you guys
tonight well I was at home
all right
it's drinking tea
and I got a phone call from my man
Stephen Hill
Stephen Hill is a great producer and he
said Gerard
really I'm honored to be making this
phone call he said uh I'm producing the
80th Golden Globes and
it would be an honor
if you would agree to join as the host
I was like whoa
you know
like one minute you're making mint tea
at home
the next you're invited to be the black
face up in in battle white organization
hilarious stuff all the jokes and this
goes on for another six minutes as
Carmichael recounts the story of how the
fascinating story of how he was offered
the job because he's a brilliant
comedian but he knew it was really
because of his race
um and then uh and he told the guy that
it's because of my race and the guy is
like no you're great
and uh told him he was really great and
and then he called his friend and he
asked her friend about it and she told
him to take the job because he's making
a lot of money for it
and and so ultimately that's what he
decided to do though he wants the Golden
Globes to know that this does not
absolve them of their racism and that
was the whole monologue that was it the
audience members laughing uncomfortably
the whole time terrified that the
cameras would show them reacting in a
way that Twitter deems inappropriate
that's that's the only funny thing about
the monologue potentially is nothing to
do with what he's saying but it's just
because people in the audience they're
like I don't know
because they know that they at any
moment that the camera could show them
and and so they're listening to a gay
black man and they're not sure is he
trying to be funny am I supposed to
laugh at this am I or if I laugh am I am
I in trouble I don't know what to do am
I supposed to be crying am I what am I
supposed to do here
so what are the problems well first of
all
um comedians are supposed to be funny
and uh you know I know this is a
controversial statement these days and
certainly will come as a great shock to
most modern comedians but comedians are
supposed to be funny that's the whole
job Gerard Carmichael isn't funny
so he doesn't seem to have understood
the assignment now you might object to
my comedians are supposed to do comedy
Theory by saying that well sometimes a
comedian might want to make a more
serious or insightful point they don't
all they don't all have to be Mitch
Hedberg up there delivering a bunch of
uh one-liners and non-sequiturs this is
true though we could only wish that most
modern comedians were as good as Mitch
Hedberg but the point is that a comedian
is supposed to make those serious and
insightful points while also being funny
that's difficult to do but those in the
profession of being funny are supposed
to be able to do that
because that's their profession
I mean literally anyone can stand up on
stage and ramble
it takes skill to not only make an
insightful point but to do it while
being funny yet that's the skill that
comedians by definition are supposed to
have
it doesn't make any sense for a comedian
to not even try to be funny it's like
going to see a juggling act instead of
juggling the juggler stands in front of
you and delivers an economics lecture
now even if the lecture is good it's got
nothing to do with juggling now
if you talk about economics while
juggling that might be interesting that
would take some actual talent
but we see this sort of thing all over
society and not just with comedians
there's a severe lack of talent
particularly in the Arts so we lack
talented comedians artists painters
musicians poets filmmakers
these are the people who who don't
actually
have the talents necessary to perform
their craft at a high level so they
compensate by pretending that they're
being bad on purpose
that's like our whole culture now is
just is is you're bad at it but you're
pretending it's on purpose
we've made bad into its own style its
own genre
so that we can all pretend that the
artist is engaging in some kind of bold
deconstruction of the art form instead
of facing the fact that he just simply
sucks at his job
second Carmichael allowed himself to be
the token black guy the diversity hire
he thinks he can get around this or
negate it by acknowledging it up front
he thinks that you know that makes the
whole performance meta and subversive
when in reality he's just a sellout with
an imaginate without an imagination
this is another thing we see all the
time now in art especially anything
involving Hollywood
is constantly making bad films that uh
that and there are films that
acknowledge their own Badness and that
acknowledgment is supposed to in itself
transform the Badness into something
good
superhero movies are the worst offenders
of this sort of thing
these films they they wink at the
audience constantly admitting to the
corny and cliched nature of the whole
thing while continuing along doing the
corny and cliche thing
now this might have been funny the first
time it was done 20 years ago but 100
movies and a thousand weeks later it's
just a crutch used by lazy boring
writers in fact it's gotten so bad now
that the finale of the She-Hulk series
um the the season finale which of course
I didn't watch but from what I read
it actually had the character She-Hulk
walk through the screen and confront the
writers of her own show to complain
about the bad writing
now this was supposed to be subversive
once again it's self-aware and funny but
instead it was just a direct admission
by the writers that they are not good at
their jobs
it's not just superhero movies in Glass
Onion the sequel to Knives Out the
detective solves the murder discovering
that it was the most obvious culprit all
along like it's the guy that was obvious
it was obviously that guy the whole
movie and then in the end they said yep
it was that guy right you had its fall
from the beginning
and then he repeatedly acknowledges the
detective does in the film that the
murderer is stupid and obvious and lazy
which is just another way of
acknowledging that the writer of the
film is himself stupid obvious and lazy
these people have so thoroughly run out
of things to say that now they're
actually talking about how they have
nothing to say
third most importantly even if we can
forgive Carmichael for being an unfunny
sellout and we're willing to sit back
and listen to his lecture we'll discover
that what he's saying about race is not
the slightest bit Brave or bold or risky
that's how it was Saul that's how the
media reacted to it
they said it was blistering because it
was a blistering monologue and there
were people on social media say it was
it was brilliant it was Brave it was
courageous
well it can never be brave for a liberal
black person to confront a bunch of
white people about their racism there is
no version of a white people or racist
speech delivered by a black person that
can ever be brave in our culture
the reason it cannot be brave is that it
has been done a million times already
and every time it's done it is
guaranteed to be applauded by all of the
most powerful people in the country
including and especially the ones you're
calling racist
you cannot be brave if you're saying
something that every Hollywood executive
and Fortune 500 CEO and politician would
publicly agree with
even if what you're saying is right it
can't possibly be brave there's nothing
Brave about your willingness to be
applauded for being brave
now if Carmichael wanted to actually be
brave and subversive and transgressive
he would have stood in front of that
audience and would have told them that
as a black man he is not oppressed in
America that um anti-black systemic
racism is imaginary and that white guilt
is a disease infecting a large portion
of the population including everyone
sitting in that room
now that would have been a bold
statement on a stage like that
it would have also easily been you know
much funnier
or you know what
maybe strike that because even more
subversive
and certainly uh more funny
would be to say nothing at all about
race okay the truly bold move would be
for the first black person
and not only that but a black gay person
to host the Golden Globes and then give
a monologue that isn't about being the
first black person to hold the host the
Golden Globes
okay in that environment in that
atmosphere for that guy to stand up
there and give a monologue that that
where he's telling jokes
that aren't about the fact that he's
black
now that would be a curveball
that's something that nobody would see
coming
but instead he went the safe route and
the unfunny route and that ultimately is
why he is today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block you can become a member today and
you use code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over there if not talk to you
tomorrow or rather talk to you next week
but we have two more kids
um Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]